the health and social care sectors are
facing a difficult winter
cases are stacked up into the millions
cobid isn't beaten
and now there's the awkward issue of
whether care workers should be compelled
to
tap the jab
as a condition of employment
and then there's the cut to universal
credit
at the center of many of these tricky
issues are low-paid workers represented
by britain's biggest unit union unison
their general secretary christine mciner
is here and she joins me thank you very
much
for getting into the seat so quickly
um
the
the the conference is of course going to
be talking a lot about
this weekend's issues but i i want to um
besides welcoming you to sky news i
think it's first time you've been on
this program uh i i want to start with
the issue
that is bread and butter for you um
there are 40 000
workers we think probably in the health
and social care sector who have not been
vaccinated the government
or yet to be vaccinated the government
says that if people aren't vaccinated by
november they could lose their job
what's the union's position
on the government's
decision that vaccinations should be a
condition of employment
we think it's wrong i think it's the
wrong thing to do and when we've been
speaking to our members who work in
social care and we're the biggest social
care union
the vast majority of them the majority
of them are vaccinated and we've we've
done everything we can as as unison to
say to them get vaccinated these are the
reasons why you should be vaccinated and
i think peer pressure can be a good way
and people giving them reassurance about
what happened when they got vaccinated
i think going down the compulsion route
is just counterproductive and people who
have genuinely got either conditions or
concerns about why they can't be
vaccinated or don't want to be
vaccinated at this point given where we
are in the pandemic they'll just leave
they'll eat they'll you know they'll
walk they'll walk away from the job and
we're not unique in saying this so we're
actually it's the government to sort of
step here we're actually you know saying
the same thing as most of the providers
are saying uh and so we've said to the
government why are you doing it this way
there must be other things we can do the
sector's already in total crisis it
wasn't crisis before the pandemic which
just made it eve then the pandemic made
it so much worse
uh you know there's over what about 120
000 vacancies at the moment uh it's just
well there'll be more believable
there'll be more vacancy is now
presumably if people uh decide that they
will rather not work than have the jab
and this is at the beginning of the
winter yeah now um
what is it that could be done about this
so what we've said to the government is
do more persuasion and actually find out
why people aren't getting vaccinated now
there may be some reasons why certain
people refuse to get vaccinated there is
still nervousness among groups and
you've got to give them full information
about why what happens when you get
vaccinated why it's a good thing to be
vaccinated
there are some kind of basic
issues that you could deal with as well
so many of them as you know trevor are
low-paid workers many of them
don't get paid sick pay when they're
offset even with covert related
illnesses
and
they're worried if they go and get a job
and they're unwell for a few days or
even a week
they're off sick they get no pay
so that's one issue i'm not saying it's
the major issue but it's certainly one
issue
making it easier for people to get the
job um
actually bringing them along with groups
with other workers to say this is what
happened when i got vaccinated this is
what this is what happened to me this is
why it's important there's lots of
persuasion you could do rather than
coercion so but of course right now
there are tens of thousands who
haven't even had the first jab and
unless the gap between first and second
jabs is
dramatically reduced they won't be in a
position by the november deadline if
that happened
um is that going to be a cause for
industrial action i mean how are you
going to resolve this so we are looking
at we're looking at we're looking at
legal advice and what we can do to
support our members we've got lots of
advice out there we've been contacting
them directly
what we're saying
and we're talking to employers as well
saying let's see if we can find a way
through this is there something else we
can do
are there some other jobs they can be
put in in the meantime while we still
try and persuade people to get this done
that actually sacking people is not a
good idea because it may be that once
people have thought about it a bit more
they will come back but as you say if
they can't hit that that deadline then
that's it they're out
and so we're trying to say to them and
to the government let's be a bit more
flexible about this and i think there's
a terrible irony here and the government
are well aware of it which is every time
i've asked them can we do something
about low p can we do something about
improving standards and training for
them they say can't do it christina we
have no levers because it's you know
it's all mainly private and voluntary
sector the government can use levers
when they want to do it because they're
clearly doing it for this okay so we've
got coverage we've got uh the 20 uh 20
pound a week cut in universal credit
which affects a lot a lot of your
members
you said that you think that this could
be the year for industrial action um now
back in 1979 it was your union the
predecessor of unison that essentially
led
that winter of discontent are we heading
for another winter of discontent well
there's certainly a lot of discontent
out there um but whether it will turn
into full-scale industrial action i
don't know that would be for the for our
members to determine we are out for
consultation at the moment we've just
been consulting on the the nhs page
on
well an indicative ballot it's called um
so it's not a formal industrial action
ballot uh which as you know is very
restrictive because of the legislation
that we've got um so we are but we're
consulting across loads of sectors so
our local government sector health
sector or police staff members uh all
being consulted on what they think about
the offer or lack of an offer that
they've been that they've been given
where will it lead i don't know yet at
this point in time for example in the
nhs
there are 16 trade unions and i used to
be the lead negotiator for those unions
so i know how difficult it is to get
consent is across them but that's the
aim is to actually talk to the other
unions in each of the sectors where
we're the main union and see how far we
can go down the road of getting some
consensus for
a plan of action shall we say going
forward
you are i think probably the first woman
leader of unison if i'm not mistaken 75
percent of your members are women that
reflects a wider
trend in the trade union movement which
is now
has more women members and
leader of the tc is a woman and so on
do you think that is going to lead to a
change in the tactics and indeed the
preoccupations the agenda of the trade
union movement
i think it will present a different
image of the trade union movement
without a doubt as in i think uh
people will see us perhaps differently
than you know
and i'm not
saying all leaders wear the kind of tub
thumping type of uh traditional image of
of a trade union leader i mean by no
means our male trade union leaders all
like that
but so to interrupt you but it's very
interesting the i think probably the
best-selling novel of the the the year
uh richard osmond the thursday murder
club has uh you've read it and it has a
guy in it who is a retired trade union
leader who is probably a mix of i don't
know ron tarden
the the old tng leader um do you think
that those days are over for that guy
uh
yeah i mean i think especially because
of the membership and it varies across
unions i mean i just look at my own
union in unison as you say 75 women a
big percentage of hers do jobs like
care workers or their nurses or their
health care assistants or uh you know
the the their
control room staff within police and and
uh ambulance centers you know there's a
huge range of jobs cleaners caterers etc
and i don't mean they're not militant i
don't mean they're not um passionate
about their rights but i think they have
a different way of expressing it in a
sense and so that old image of you know
a male of a you know a man in a in a
donkey jacket or a high-vis vest
standing around the brazier i mean
that's not where our members are our
members will take striking actually our
members will pick it they will do they
will you know stand and demonstrate
against unfairness and injustice but i
think they expect the leaders to
be able to
negotiate to talk sensibly and express
arguments on their behalf and at the end
of the day they pay us as their
officials to get deals that's what my
members asked me to do so
megaphones out out out thank you christy
mcinerney